yeah i thought that i had just made it
like right before the buzzer like you
did it like you're gonna have the chance
at living
life as a thin person and you because
that was what i've always resisted being
defined by by
like that's what i hate you know i i
don't hate it it is what it is now but
like i hated being the kid actor the
child actor because i knew that that
triggered in people's brains like for
every zendaya or or or jody foster there
were a thousand other kids that just you
know completely nose-dived in front of
the public and so i'm like i don't want
to be in that class i just want to be an
actor i don't want to be the fat funny
guy i just want to be an actor amongst
actors right
um but yeah that was
that was huge when i lost the weight it
was it was a game changer but
unfortunately i was the same head in a
new body
and
pretty quickly i got to my goal weight
and then became viciously addicted to
drugs and alcohol which took over the
next four years of my life and how did
your mom respond to that was she
heartbroken she was like you always
overdo it
she so she knew you were doing these
drugs oh yeah and she didn't she she
wasn't uh angry or upset oh yeah she was
heartbroken terrified she was yeah every
day for four years i don't think she
slept what kind of drugs did you do i
did them all cocaine oh yeah heroin
no okay well that's good because that
could have been the end of it if you did
we got went there i did you know i
mostly it was a lot of you know cocaine
and and pills and pretty much whatever
you had
uh right when i turned 18. 18. so you
finally get this new lust for life
you're thinner you you want to be this
actor you're excited you love the way
people are looking at you differently
and you [ __ ] throw it into the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you just throw the whole thing down the
drain by doing all these drugs and [ __ ]
you're just getting you're hanging out
with the wrong crowd yeah well those
kids like the ones who are going to the
clubs i was like oh
take me i've been you know my dvds are
alphabet you're getting laid at this
time
no i mean i wound up doing cocaine for
the first time because of a girl because
she was the first girl who had ever
shown me any attention
and i remember her pulling it out and
i'm at this what
not it oh oh okay okay
but maybe you know
i don't know we never got that far i
never got that i'll be honest
[Laughter]
geez
the book gets really weird around page
120 i'm sure it does it's tactic
um but no i was at this party and like i
think i'd smoke pot but that was the
extent of it and i just remember her you
know
doing cocaine with like her girlfriends
and i'm seeing it there i'm like oh this
is like pulp fiction
it's like the movies
because there's what movie stars do man
totally you kind of feel that you're
like oh i'm in hollywood and i'm doing
drugs and this is what i need to be
doing not even that far it was this is
what kids do like this is what typically
i've been working towards typical my
whole life and my whole adolescence was
besieged by you have to
mine your p's and q's don't say anything
out of turn do you want another take
boss like i'm not those other child
actors like i know my lines and i'm on
my mark like
like louder faster like am i okay will
this casting director give me a part i
just want you to think i'm okay i was in
this crazy people-pleasing
you know storm my whole life and
suddenly i'm like now looking like a
normal kid and a normal teen
and i'm like oh
they do drugs and that's normal and they
go to house parties and they go to clubs
and they show up late to places and
they're unreliable and that's normal and
i i died to be normal and i remember the
first when i fir finally said yes
i had no consensus conception that this
drug would make me feel any different
that it was extreme
all i thought was
a i hope she's watching
and oh good i'm normal
isn't that f isn't that [ __ ]
i it is to think that that's normal like
hey i need to be doing this because this
is what kids do right this is what
everybody's doing yeah it's it's it's
crazy i'm on party of five right now
like um right i'm all those 90s movies